[Music]
on this tuesday night inside war-torn
car keys
the people staying behind in the
bombarded city how they're managing to
survive
plus wariness over the latest peace
talks and russia's promise to pull back
from cube canada's latest climate plan
the road map to reduce emissions and the
billions needed to get there
signs covet isn't over in canada as
public health restrictions lift
hospitalizations climb
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is a lot of caution tonight over
promises russia has made in peace talks
with ukraine more than a month into its
invasion russia's deputy defense
minister claims it is reducing combat
operations around kiev and a northern
city saying he wants to increase mutual
trust negotiators for russia and ukraine
met face to face in istanbul today the
turkish president telling them the world
is waiting for good news but russia has
lied and broken past promises and
western leaders are not taking anything
at face value
i don't read anything into it until i
see what their actions are
we'll see if they follow through on what
they're suggesting
missiles are still flying and ukrainians
are still dying this russian attack
today on a southern port city tore a
hole through a building at least 12
people were killed
in just a moment we'll have more on
those peace talks and whether russian
forces are just buying time while
regrouping but we begin with jeff simple
in harkief a city that's been under
siege for weeks
maxime is trying to keep his children
distracted from the horrors of their
home
two weeks ago they heard an air raid
siren and ran down to the basement it
was lucky they did this is what's left
of their apartment building
there was a huge explosion everyone was
terrified he says adding his godmother
and two of their friends were killed
the family lives in harkev ukraine's
second largest city has endured the
second most russian attacks next only to
mariupol the city is hit by rockets and
artillery dozens of times each day more
than 10 percent of the buildings have
been destroyed homes schools and
shopping plazas
it's very scary we spend most of the
time hiding in our basement this couple
says the city says a third of its one
and a half million residents have fled
many who've stayed have moved
underground
victoria has spent three weeks living in
the subway with her husband daughters
and cats after their home was destroyed
why is russia doing this she asks why
hurt children why hurt old people why do
we suffer many of her extended family
members live in russia the city is
located just 40 kilometers from the
russian border and has long enjoyed
close ties with moscow
we are all russian speakers in this area
and for some reason we're shelled the
most she says we met the city's mayor in
a secret location he says his residents
have seen the hardships in the
russian-controlled regions of donetsk
and luhansk
the russians mistake was that they
thought if 90 percent of the city speaks
russian then we will greet them with
flowers he says they did not realize
that the city of harkev was
is and will be ukrainian one of the key
pretexts of russia's invasion of ukraine
was to protect
russian-speaking communities like this
one well this is what vladimir putin's
protection looks like this was an
apartment building that was shelled just
recently and as you can see that rubble
is still everywhere
the belongings of family members here
who were killed in this explosion
children's toys stuffed animals clothes
books
it is absolutely horrific
a military press officer took global
news for a tour of the aftermath we were
instructed to follow his car and were
far from the front line when we heard
gunfire
warning shots fired into the air by
ukrainian soldiers whom it turned out
hadn't been told by their colleague that
we were coming
yet another example of a city on edge
after nearly five weeks of relentless
attacks and yet many residents including
maxim's family refused to leave
we were born here and we will die here
he says today the bombing is here
tomorrow it's somewhere else we will not
run away from our homeland we will not
give up this city
that's a microphone his playful
five-year-old daughter jenna testing out
our microphone seemed blissfully unaware
of the evidence all around them that in
this war no target is off limits
then another air raid siren and the
family heads for shelter once again
jeff semple global news harkief ukraine
there are some signs russian forces are
pulling back from the capital kyiv but
the u.s believes they could be
repositioning not retreating if the goal
was to take the capital city and the
whole of ukraine vladimir putin has
failed what his next move is and whether
these peace talks in istanbul are
genuine or just a ploy is deeply
uncertain crystal gomencing reports
an ominous start to peace talks in
istanbul where ukraine warned its own
negotiators not to eat or drink anything
not even touch any surfaces
a day earlier it was revealed delegates
including russian oligarch roman
abramovich allegedly fell ill due to
poisoning but under that cloud a glimmer
of hope that progress could be made with
nato member turkey seated between the
two warring nations ukraine offered to
remain outside of any military alliance
and not host foreign military bases but
it wants foreign nations such as turkey
the u.s even canada to act as security
guarantors signing on to legally protect
ukraine
and it opened the door to negotiations
on the future of disrupted territories
the crimean peninsula which was annexed
by russia in 2014 and the contested
separatist regions in donetsk and
luhansk which russia recognizes as
independent states but before a deal can
move forward ukrainians first have to
agree
constructive
the talks were constructive says the
head of the russian delegation we
received the ukrainian side's proposal
for consideration
french president emmanuel macron has
continued to engage in dialogue directly
with vladimir putin and he spoke to his
counterparts from the uk germany and the
u.s
all agreeing to keep pushing for russia
to fully withdraw its troops
russian officials said it would
radically reduce forces around keefe and
chernihiv to facilitate mutual trust
skeptical american officials say the
rollback could also be repositioning
russia has failed in its objective of
capturing keefe it's failed in its
objective of subjugating ukraine
but they can still inflict
massive brutality on the country
including on kiev this is an example of
what russia is still doing daily all
over ukraine a missile tore through a
government building early tuesday
morning
the deadly attack prompting yet another
frantic rescue and recovery effort
it's just a nightmare she says a girl
died on my floor
while ukrainians hope for peace they are
still waiting for any sign of it on the
ground it was suggested direct talks
between the two leaders
could be possible
crystal gamansen global news london
ukraine's proposal to adopt neutral
status in exchange for security
guarantees includes having canada as one
of the countries acting as a security
guarantor it would mean ukraine would
not join any military alliances or host
any military bases eric sorenson looks
at what that might involve and what it
could mean for canada
for seven years canadian forces trained
thousands of ukrainian troops a level of
trust and interoperability has been
established that puts this country on
ukraine's list of potential security
guarantors we've been in close contact
with our ukrainian counterparts since
the beginning of this crisis the foreign
affairs minister wouldn't address it but
could a role emerge as negotiators for
ukraine and russia create some daylight
on ceasefire talks
the aim says this ukrainian presidential
advisor is to receive security
guarantees to stop the conflict one
defense expert sees a possible role for
canada as a peacekeeping nation with
relationships among many countries
historically this aligns with canada's
contributions it is entirely conceivable
that canada
will be looking to leverage
those relationships uh to play a
possible role as
as an honest broker and a security
grudger among the possible security
guarantor nations named by ukraine
turkey and israel which have maintained
relations with russia poland the nation
that has absorbed the most ukrainian
refugees and canada this country is
currently in latvia where canadian
forces lead a nato mission and canada's
military was on the ground until
recently in ukraine with operation
unifier a relationship that is long
standing and deep
as recently as eight weeks ago canada's
defense minister was in kiev shortly
before canadian military trainers pulled
out of ukraine we trained over
well thirty thousand ukrainian forces
and they're showing themselves proving
their medal in the battlefield so we
bring with us all kinds of um
interoperability skills and um
alliance links that can be used by
ukraine to increase the security a
ceasefire is not at hand but a security
force would have to be ready to go
quickly canada has a significant
experience with ukrainian bureaucracy
and in particular with the ukrainian
defense establishment if and when a
request comes for canada to play a role
in ukraine's future security one source
in ottawa told global news the
government will consider it erik
sorensen global news toronto
albertans have begun welcoming
ukrainians fleeing the war
more than 60 people were greeted with
cheers and applause as they arrived in
edmonton from poland last night most
have family connections in alberta the
plane they came on is now picking up
donated supplies to take back to ukraine
via poland
the u.n refugee agency says nearly four
million people have fled ukraine since
the invasion began about six and a half
million have been displaced inside the
country u n aid organizations say
they've helped up to 900 000 people in
ukraine but they need to be guaranteed
safe passage to do more
canada is sending more rcmp officers to
help the international criminal court
investigate whether russia has committed
war crimes the federal government says
the officers will use their expertise to
collect evidence which may be used in an
eventual prosecution the icc launched an
investigation earlier this month at the
request of canada and 38 other member
states amnesty international also
accuses russia of committing war crimes
particularly in mariupol where about 160
000 civilians have been trapped for
weeks with no power and little food
in other news tonight the indigenous
delegation in rome toured the vatican
museums today a day after the first
private meetings with pope francis to
talk about the catholic church's role in
the residential school system the
museum's house the church's private
collection of artwork archaeology and
historical artifacts among them are
thousands of culturally significant
indigenous pieces some are centuries old
and rarely viewed
indigenous peoples from around the world
have requested access to them including
the metis nation
we are going to try to meet with the
director of each of the
museums that we do tour today
and work to find out and start
cataloging the items that might actually
belong to the nation
private meetings will resume on thursday
and all the delegates will gather with
pope francis on friday
the multi-billion dollar blueprint to
get greener coming up canada's latest
plan to slash greenhouse gas emissions
next federal budget will be delivered on
april 7th and a big part of the focus
will be climate change all previous
plans to cut emissions have failed to
reach their targets and today prime
minister justin trudeau laid out the
latest one this plan includes 9.1
billion dollars in new spending and aims
to reduce emissions more than 40 percent
below 2005 levels by 2030. as abigail
beamon reports that includes a 42 cut to
carbon emissions from the oil and gas
sector this is our boldest and most
specific step yet the
271-page plan to get to net zero by 2050
looks at each emission-producing sector
and offers some solutions they include
mandating a hundred percent of new
vehicle sales to be zero emission cars
by 2035 sticking to the carbon tax with
an increase to 170 dollars per ton by
2030 and focusing more on electricity
aiming to make it net zero by twenty
thirty five big oil lobbyists
have had their time on the field
now it's over to the workers and
engineers who will build solutions tough
talk from the prime minister but no
specifics in terms of hard caps on
emissions from oil and gas the plan
calls for a 42 emissions reduction by
2030 from the industry but the
government is still exploring how to get
there they're going to consult they're
going to look down the road this entire
plan
is about greenwashing
canada's oil industry i would put their
feet to the fire so i i would say you
know we need to see a lot in the next 6
to 12 months in addition to oil and gas
this roadmap looks at what kinds of
emission cuts are possible by 2030 from
all industries electricity has the most
room to cut agriculture and
transportation the least this isn't a
fully developed plan at all it doesn't
even pretend to be this is a fully
developed
indicative understanding
of what we might do if we had a plan
they haven't met a single emissions
target yet
some experts are applauding the plan
while calling for more details
especially who is responsible for what
by when and for what cost two truths can
coexist at the same time this can be at
the same time the most transparent and
detailed climate plan that canada has
ever seen and still be
insufficient officials promise pricing
details for the 9.1 billion dollars will
come in next week's budget and while the
ndp are critical their budget support in
a confidence vote through the new
liberal ndp deal is not in question
abigail beeman global news ottawa
stealth omicron ahead how canadians
should brace for the latest covid19 wave
[Music]
public health restrictions have been
lifted across much of the country but
the pandemic is not over vaccines have
certainly saved lives but in some
provinces hospitalizations for covet 19
are on the rise again jamie morocco
explains what's happening and what we
should prepare for
just as quickly as masks have come off
health experts are now recommending we
put them back on it's pretty clear that
there's more covid now than there was a
week ago and two weeks ago and we're at
the very early parts of a wave cases of
the omicron subvariant ba2 sometimes
referred to as stealth omicron are
rising nationally in nova scotia and new
brunswick there's more health care
workers becoming infected wastewater
data from ontario and alberta has shown
an increase in the virus and over the
weekend covet hospitalization started to
rise in bc and that's not the only
province when you see an increase in the
community cases as
an indirect measure you you have to be
concerned um that there will be an
increase in hospitalizations and in fact
at least in quebec we are starting to
see an increase in the hospitalization
stealth omicron has been blamed for a
tsunami of kova cases in china the uk
germany and france but only the latter
has recently experienced record
hospitalization rates another concern is
ba2's ability to break through
vaccination and re-infect those who've
already had covet dr allison mcgear says
the timing of this wave for older
canadians who are now four to five
months out from their booster is
concerning
their protection from severe disease
will have dropped from
somewhere in the 90s right after their
third dose
down to
somewhere maybe just below 80 percent
and while that doesn't sound like a big
drop
it's actually a doubling right the us
fda has approved fourth doses for all
americans over 50. in canada it's
residents of long-term care and
immunocompromised adults who are
currently eligible it's not the answer
but it's part of this multi-layered
approach to trying to control cases and
obviously control severe illness and
death an approach we are all too
familiar with two years in but it's
whether we decide to react with personal
protective measures or choose to ignore
the warnings experts say that will
determine the impact of this spring
surge jamie morocco global news toronto
everybody on there phoenix what are the
owner eugene melnick
businessman eugene melnick owner of the
ottawa senators has died his family and
the organization said he passed away
after an illness melnick bought the
senators in 2003 when the team was
facing bankruptcy and under his tenure
the club made the playoffs nine times
including a run in the 2007 stanley cup
final mel nick was 62 years old
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with the latest inductee to the
canadian music hall of fame
deborah cox winner of three junos is the
first black woman to be inducted into
the hall of fame known for 90s hits like
nobody's supposed to be here the
toronto-born r b singer is joining the
ranks of joni mitchell and the
tragically hip she'll receive the honor
at the juno awards in may
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
bye
[Music]
i'm through